the world's many democracies are all
varied and unique
they have their own story to tell
their own imperfections to work on
and their own meaning to their people
but they also have many things in common
such as the freedom they give people to
say to do
and to choose
and our history here in europe like in
so many other places
also shows us
that democracies are closely linked to
each other
democratic progress in one country
so often spreads fast through a whole
region
as it did in so many parts of europe in
the last 50 years
in that time we have seen the power
democracy has to create momentum
and a believe that positive change is
possible
but we have also learned that the
erosion of democracy
and the silent rise of autocracy
can spread just as fast
we know how painful it is
when a small group takes unlimited power
and imposes a single vision on all of
society we saw it after the second world
war
and we know it can happen again
and the most fertile ground for this
is
we're targeted to disinformation
skews the way
we see democracy and perceive the world
or where people feel
that democracy does not work for them
so together the world's democracies
with all our flaws and challenges
must show
that democracy can deliver
to improve people's lives
and to tackle the biggest global
challenges we face
this is what the european commission is
committed to doing
it is why we have put forward measures
to help protect people
online from illegal content
hidden political advertisement
or disinformation
it is why we are proposing to add hate
speech and hate crime
to the list of crimes in our treaties
it is why we are giving people a greater
voice
through the conference on the future of
europe
it is why we will step up our work to
tackle corruption or to protect
journalists with a new media freedom act
and it is why just last week
we presented global gateway
our values-driven plan to invest in the
infrastructure the world needs for the
future
none of us have all the answers
and all of us have our own issues
so we must work on them
because while democracy is not perfect
it is perfectable
and that is the difference between
democracy and autocracy
in democracies you can criticize
you can protest
and you can freely discuss opposing
ideas
that's freedom
so let's stand up for it
let's take up the challenge together
because the destiny of our democracies
depends on each other
this is why i am determined to help make
this summit for democracy
a real starting point for positive
change